SAW THEM LOSE THEIR LAST GAME IY
FOR THTHEY HAVE NICE NUMBERS CO
INTO THE ZONE.
THREE GUYS ACROSS.
AND I THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT  E
HERE IS KARLSSON AND MEIER
UYS GD
IN PLAY.
AND THE GUY THAT DOES THE  AND
SCORESAT ALLOWS HIM TO JUME CORR
AGAINST LINDGREN
HERE IS KREIDER ALL THMERKLEY.
AND HE'LL COME AHEAD
GOOD PLA K'ANDRE MILLER.
FERRARO IS THERE TO GET IT AWAY
FROM PANARIN
AND D
BOY, SURE LOOKS LIKE HE WANTS TO
STAY IN THW THE -- YOU LOOK
AT IT.
WE SEE THE PUCK CROSS THE LINE
AT ALL FOR THE
RANGERS.
GRECO WITH STROME.
A SAVE BY HILL AND ANOTHER BY
HILLAS THE SHARKS ARE A
LITTLE BIT SCRAMBLE MODE R RSTRE
HERE IS HERTL.
N CENTERS IT
ON THE SAVS BLADE.
JAMMED OUT OF THERE BY THEO MEI
A LITTLE BIT LATE.
AND LOOK AT OMING
IN
GOES WIDE, GOES TO THE RIGHTE OY
GOAL
CHYTIL, BACK ANDT OVER
THEY GOT HIGH DANGER AREA.
AND TH
MEGNA, KREIDER, AND HE HIT THE
OUTSIDE OF THE NET HANDED A MON
THIS
PLAYERS, BECAUSE HE KNOWS THEM
ALL SO
HERE'S COGLIANAD THE
BLOCKED.
SHARKS COME BACK WITH NUMBERS.BR
SHARK, EVER TO START
WITH THE SAN JOSE SHARKS
THEY GET THE FORE-CHECK
THAT WILL DO IT.